hallo ihr lieben heutigen lecker
zitronen blechkuchen und zwar einer der
nicht nur fluffig ist sondern auch
saftig und wie das geht das zeige ich
euch jetzt denn wir bereiten zu
allererst den teig zu
wir benötigen mehr speisestärke
backpulver eine prise salz hier habe ich
ja in eigelb und eiweiß getrennt
außerdem butter oder margarine zucker
und zitronen sowie hat er die eier
getrennt in eigelb und eiweiß und zwar
deshalb weil wir das jetzt zu einer pc
masse aufschlagen und wenn wir die dann
in den teig einräumt dann wird er
nämlich richtig schön fluffig wichtig
ist nur dass die küchenmaschine sauber
ist und auch den schneebesen aufsatz und
falls ihr keine küchenmaschine habt dann
nimmt durch ein handrührgerät und ich
geb dir jetzt auch noch eine prise salz
dazu das kann die altersstruktur bisher
zerstört und dann wird das ganze
aufgeschlagen erst mal so eine minute
auf höchster stufe und dann geht's
weiter
[Musik]
die masse ist schon richtig schön dick
schau mich jetzt geben wir aber die
hälfte des zuckers mit hinzu und das
bewirkt einfach das ganze richtig schön
fest steht und jetzt nochmal zwei
weitere minuten auf polsterstoffe
schlagen so die bwb masse ist und sie
ist richtig schön fest gebe ich jetzt
allerdings ganz gut nochmal an die seite
wenn wir machen weiter mit den
restlichen zutaten und dafür hole ich
mir ein anderes schüssel so in der
schüssel wird jetzt die butter bzw die
margarine aufgeschlagen zusammen mit dem
restlichen zucker und das ganze so für
ungefähr 23 minuten bis die masse schön
weiß cremig ist
[Musik]
für die butter messe wird richtig
schönfeld cremig und jetzt kommt das
eigelb mit ins spiel und unser
zitronensaft wenn ihr bio zitrone habt
ihr habe ich jetzt leider nicht dann
nimmt auf jeden fall auch den abtrieb
der schale steckt auch super und das
gebe ich jetzt nach und nach dazu und
anschließend auch noch den zitronensaft
und dann verlieren wir das einfach nur
so lange bis es sich komplett verbunden
hat
[Musik]
zwei gelb und zitronensaft sind jetzt in
der butter masse und jetzt nehmen wir
uns die trockenen zutaten vor hier
versuche ich einfach speisestärke mehl
und backpulver miteinander und das müsst
ihr jetzt auch nicht sieben denn es
entstehen keine klumpen im teig verrührt
das jetzt nur so ganz grob und dann gebe
ich das auf niedriger stufe mit zur
butter masse
[Musik]
im letzten schritt müssen wir nur noch
unsere cremigen masse hier die baiser
mast hinzufügen und das mache ich immer
am liebsten mit einem teig schaber in
zwei bis drei schritten und schön
vorsichtig dass die luft nicht ausgeht
[Musik]
wieso der teig ist fertig und ist so
schön fluffig guckt euch mal an so wie
sie aussehen und jetzt habe ich hier
schon meinen back rahmen bereit gelegt
ihr könnt auch ohne back raum backnang
besorgt den geraden abschluss natürlich
wird das ganze dadurch 1 cm kleiner wird
euch auch die masse unten in die infobox
schreiben und jetzt fühlen wir den tag
einfach ein und streifen ihnen etwas
klatsch und sobald ihr den teig schön
glatt verstrichen habt kommt er in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze für ca 22 minuten aus
untere drittel vom backofen macht auf
jeden fall ein stäbchen probe
bis gleich so der teig ist fertig
gebacken und ich hab ihn auskühlen dass
nun der ganze raum riecht nach zitrone
und jetzt nehme ich mir meinen kuchen
einen teil alle techniken und welchen
dass so ein bisschen einteilen damit
einfach auch schön aussieht müsst ihr
natürlich nicht ihr könnt auch ganz
normal teure stückchen durchschneiden so
und dann nehmt ihr euch eine ein messer
am besten mit wellenschliff damit ihr
das richtig schön durchschneien könnte
[Musik]
war ich bin ja schlau ich habe mir
diesen einteiler benutzt dann bin ich
hier solche verschnitte habe und die
können wir dann jetzt ist aber sagt kein
[Musik]
so ihr lieben für einen zitronenkuchen
ist immer so klassischerweise der
zuckerguss noch so als topping zuständig
und ich finde es auch ganz gut wobei ich
anmerken muss dass er diesen
zitronenkuchen auch so naturell sagt man
das so ohne alles ist ein könnt wirklich
ja wir machen mit dem zuckerguss den
kennt ihr alle
das ist ganz einfach puderzucker mit
etwas zitronensaft vermischen so dass
die konsistenz etwas fester wird und
nicht zu flüssig und dann der chor ist
später auch noch schön mit
zitronenscheiben und minze mintzel ist
auch mal gut
[Musik]
so ihr lieben fertig dekoriert sind die
zitronen schnittchen jetzt endlich
bereits zum vernaschen und ich sag dir
also die schmecken auch ohne bus total
lecker aber so sieht es noch mal ein
bisschen hübscher aus und das ist das
leckerste zitronen blechkuchen rezept
das ich persönlich kenne
ihr müsst das ist mal eine ansage das
sage ich seltenen ich finde man kann nie
sagen das ist das leckerste und das ist
das leckerste aber das ist so also das
muss eben wirklich mal ausprobieren die
genauen mengenangaben schreibt euch
natürlich wie immer hier unten in die
infobox ich möchte von euch ich möchte
fotos mit dem herzstück des kitchen oft
ins erste treffen dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder genau das tablett lässt
sich schon ein stückchen haben wir
gerade den postboten geben und er war
auch hellauf begeistert also macht
unbedingt nach ich verspreche euch
dieses rezept wird euch so gut gefallen
und ansonsten freue ich mich natürlich
wenn ihr diesem video eindeutig nach
oben gibt main kanal natürlich kostenlos
abonniert denn dann sehen wir uns auch
beim nächsten mal wieder auf kritik
sketchen tschüss